[Music]
russell now joins us in phoenix arizona
russell how can we help
well yeah uh how you guys doing we're
having a blast what's going on with you
uh so a quick um funny story uh when you
were uh trying to sing in the last
segment i'm actually a voice teacher
oh well no i want to point out that
i wish i was on the phone now yeah but i
didn't try to sing there was no there
was no attempt at all i actually held
back because i needed to work the melody
out in my head but i do appreciate that
you're available in case i decide to do
that after the end of your question
thanks for the disclaimer yes
um no so the reason i was calling was um
so i'm just starting my journey on
uh the baby steps and uh because i've
been listening to the show for a few
weeks and finally you know gone the
website and
said you know it's time to do this so
um at this point um on my base up one
with the emergency fund and
i got the every dollar wrap to start
creating my budget
uh which i've never done before with my
my wife and i so i can be pretty new but
as i'm doing this process i've been
creating
gathering all of our debts and all that
all of our things
and trying to and just getting ready for
the snowball once we get our emergency
fund and the question i have for you
guys is
um my car loans
so i've heard you know listen to show
you you know try to sell the cars off
you know get rid of that if possible
but unfortunately on my car loans
all of them i am too far negative
to be able to cover the negative is just
outright seldom
so my question
is
on the snowball usually smallest largest
if i know i need to pay an additional
eight grand off my car
where i can break even
should i move the car up to an eight
thousand dollar instead if i owe
eighteen thousand so if i moved up to an
eight thousand dollar in my snowball
to pay that off and then sell it to get
rid of that debt instead of leaving the
18 000 car run lower on the snowball
hmm based on what you told me it doesn't
sound like that makes the most sense
what are the cars worth
okay so
um
there's three cars
so the the smallest one which i owe 18
the car is worth about 10.
okay
the next one
i owe 32
and it's probably worth about 24.
all right
and then the biggest one
i owe 60
that's probably worth 50.
what's your household
uh income home is right under a hundred
thousand a year
what's the gross on that
probably a hundred thirty i don't know
somewhere around there yeah you have
hundred and ten thousand dollars in car
loans which is more than you make in a
year and our rule of thumb is to have
all that add up to no more than half of
your annual income and so
we have to get rid of these cards
regardless i'm gonna do the lesser of
the evils here could you sell the 61 for
50
and make up the difference because
that's the biggest one anyways
i don't have the 10 i don't have the
negative to cover at this point no so we
the only time we tell people it's okay
to go get you know a loan from a credit
union or local bank is when they're
under water on a car like this now i
don't want you to go rack up another 30
grand in personal loans and just move
the debt around but if we can get rid of
these cars and then have a much smaller
loan to face i'm okay with that
that was my thinking as well i just want
to kind of confirm um if that should be
a good option to go that route the
question is how are you this far
underwater with a car market like we
have right now
uh bad impulsive decisions on my wife
and my decisions uh
like the that newest one that 60 000
cargo and we just got that probably a
few months back before i started
listening to the ramsay show and in a
few months it's already appreciated that
much
it's already depreciated that much in a
few months
well yeah well they marked it up pretty
i didn't realize how much you marked it
up so i wasn't yeah
that's what i was doing
and why do you guys need three cars
do you have three drivers we do
no again with the three car thing
uh
bad decision
my wife was impulsive on one in a third
car because she won't put a bunch of
miles on her car
and she regrets it now is but yeah she
got in the idea that she could afford a
small payment and not put so many miles
on her car since she drives so far to
work
so unfortunately we have three cars okay
what other debt do you have
we've got
credit cards so credit card is probably
maybe 11 to 12 grand worth
then
student loans
about
18 000
and then a solar loan for 40 000. oh boy
okay i'm gonna put you guys through
financial peace university on us it's
our gift to you uh that's all part of
ramsay plus including every dollar
premium you said you just started your
first every dollar budget and so what i
want you to do is watch the lessons with
your wife have a conversation after each
lesson with takeaways an action plan do
the every dollar premium budget which is
going to connect to your bank account
this is an emergency situation
this is not like ah yeah we're gonna do
the debt this is we don't see
a restaurant we don't see a
drive-through this is rice and beans
this is cutting every expense possible
you guys have been living la vida loca
and uh it's time to stop and be adults
so we're rooting for you i hope this
gift helps so hang on austin's gonna
pick up we'll get you plugged into that